نفسها بانها شركه امنيه خاصه ويراها اخرون
اقرب ما تكون الى ميليشيا تطورت الى شبكه
موازيه عابره للقارات تتدخل وتدافع عن
المصالح الروسيه حيثما دعت الحاجه وحيثما
اخفقت القوات النظاميه اخر هذه المواقع
جبهه بخموت التي حققت فيها ميليشيا فاجنر
اختراقا احرج الجيش الروسي وسط اتهامات من
قياده ميليشيا للجيش بخيانه قواتها ومنع
الذخيره عنها هي الان في ملكيه رجل
الاعمال
الذي يحمل لقبه طباخ بوتين في اشاره لكونه
صاحب شركه كونكورد المختصه في توفير
الطعام ثم حصل على عقود تمويل الجيش
الروسي لتتضاعف ثروته بشكل سريع كان اول
ظهور لقوات فاجنر بعد ضم روسيا لشبه جزيره
القرم عام 2014 حين قاتلت على الجبهات
وساعدت الانفصاليين المدعومين روسيا
وبعدها توسع نفوذها انتشارها واكتسبت
المجموعه سمعتها تشير تقديرات الاستخبارات
الغربيه الى ان عدد مقاتلي المجموعه في
اوكرانيا انتقل من عشره الاف مقاتل الى
خمسين الفا لتشكل ما يقارب خموس القوات
الروسيه المنتشره على الجبهات افتتح
بريكوجن اول مقر لفاجنر في مدينه
بالمناسبه قال ان مهمه مركز فاجنر هي
توفير بيئه مريحه لتوليد افكار جديده بغيت
تحسين القدره الدفاعيه لروسيا وتحسين
القدره الدفاعيه للروسيا لا يمكنه اخفاء
حقيقه الاتهامات لفاجنر بارسال مسلحها الى
عده دول في امريكا اللاتينيه وافريقيا
وتنفيذ ما توصف بعمليات قذره في مناطق
النزاع المختلفه